وهكذا تبدأ في صباح صيفي مشمس ، قام
العاملون في مشرحة كييف المركزية
بفحص محتويات 160
كيسًا قذرًا للجثث تحتوي على رفات متحللة بشكل سيئ
لجنود قتلوا خلال
الحصار الذي دام شهرين في مدينة
ماريوبول الساحلية وفي المدينة.
مصنع فولاذي مترامي الأطراف على طراز آزوف ، حيث
اتخذت القوات الأوكرانية آخر موقف لها ،
أجرت أوكرانيا وروسيا
تبادلًا للجثث كجزء من
الاتفاقية التي أنهت الحصار ، حيث
تعمل الفاحصة الجنائية ليليا فيليبشوك
منذ ثلاث سنوات منذ
بدء الحرب.
قمنا أيضًا بفحص الجثث من بوشان
إيربين التي تقول إنها
تشير إلى ضواحي كييف حيث
اتُهمت القوات الروسية المنسحبة
بارتكاب فظائع ضد المدنيين ،
كما تساعد إيلينا تولكاتشوفا
التابعة لواء آزوف الذي
قاتل في ماريوبول ، اللواء هو
ميليشيا قومية تم دمجها
في  القوات المسلحة الأوكرانية ،
المشرحة مليئة بالفعل بالجثث المأخوذة
من مفتاح من bucha من الأذن ، كما تقول ،
لذا يتعين علينا وضعها في شاحنة ثلاجة
للبحث في الملابس الممزقة والممزقة
عن المستندات والعلامات وحقيبة
الأغراض الشخصية ، هذه مجرد بداية
عملية طويلة
بعض هذه الجثث ليس لديها
هوية لذلك يجب أخذ عينات من الحمض النووي الخاص بهم
وقد يستغرق الأمر شهرًا وربما أكثر
لمعرفة من هم
بن سي إن إن